und leute wenn ich von anfang an bis zum
ende begleitet sage meine ich das auch
so denn auch die auslieferung werde ich
bei drei bestellungen persönlich machen
hey leute ich könnte jetzt in diesem
video das übertrieben sste klick dating
machten wir irgendwann total
abgesperrten titel ausdenken so dass
jeder drauf klickt oder ich können sowie
die ein oder andere youtuber denn was
erzählen von wegen wenn sie gar nicht so
viel gemacht hat eine stunde kommen aber
darauf habe ich keinen bock leute diese
sache die ich heute zeige von der vierte
erzähle
die liegt mir wirklich wirklich wirklich
am herzen deswegen machen es jetzt
authentisch face to face
es ist ja gerade die weihnachtszeit
leute und in der weihnachtszeit
selbstverständlich bringen sehr sehr
viele menschen es raus ich dieses jahr
zum aller ersten mal auch darum für
einen youtube ist es aber so dass sie
ihre merchandise zu einem gewissen teil
selbst machen das heißt in ungefähr
allen fällen stehen noch unternehmen
dazwischen was ich zum beispiel für die
supply ab dem 12 spreadshirt oder wie
wolf oder hollywood was diese
unternehmen machen ist sie arbeiten mit
youtuber zusammen neben youtube an die
arbeit ab so dass sie nur sagen müssen
okay das design ist cool dass nicht nur
das in ruhe machen denke ich kann mich
meine videos so funktioniert es
normalerweise wenn unternehmen dabei
sind sie neben ihrer arbeit ab und
youtuber zahlen dafür einen gewissen
anteil dieser unternehmen von den
verkäufen bei uns ist das ganz anders
wir machen alles 100 prozent selbst bei
diesem merchandise habe ich von anfang
an vom design über die auswahl der
materialien über die aussetzung des
shops über jedes einzelne verdammte
telefon ja jede einzelne sekunde der
eingang
ist alles zu 100 prozent selbst gemacht
kein unternehmen ist dabei und das heißt
natürlich im gegenzug dass ihr mit
meinen mädchen da ist auch wirklich nur
mich unterstützt er bekommt kein anderes
unternehmen irgendwie land hält 20
prozent oder sowas ab sondern jeder
einzelne cent aus dem erlös geht an mich
niemand anderen wir jetzt mal darüber
was hier steht ihr habt ihr schon
gesehen das steht irgendwie was
chinesisch assistentin john cho dreier
und somit dax bitte was hier steht ist
ein japanischer schriftzug und der steht
für underdog jetzt fragt ihr euch
vielleicht warum anders wieso nicht drei
rollen laxey umfrage leute die antwort
ist das hier steht einfach für mich
underdog das war ich schon mein ganzes
leben lang das ist einfach ist er für
die geschichte meines lebens in
merchandise verpackt als andere doch
bezeichnet man im allgemeinen einen
menschen der außen steht oder eine
person an die leute nicht glauben von
die leute nicht denken dass sie es
schaffen könnte und das ist eine rolle
die ich eigentlich mein ganzes leben
lang schon hatte ich habe ja schon mal
in dem video über probleme geredet die
ich früher in der schulzeit hatte als
ich die schule gewechselt habe euch in
der acht neun zehn katastrophale
probleme wir haben mit ihren habe ich
noch in eine situation am ende der
achten klasse hätte ich so schlechte
noten für hier 54 56 ich hätte wirklich
katastrophal noten und ich erinnere mich
in eine situation bei weichen dem
gespräch mit dem lehrer mit dem
schuldirektor und mit meinen eltern und
der lehrer hat gesagt
wissen sie was zu meinen eltern in der
sebastian sie sollten von der achten
klasse nicht versetzen das macht glaube
ich keinen sinn die schulischen leistung
sind einfach nicht gut genug meine
eltern haben gesagt ja wir wissen nicht
so wirklich aus wieder machen soll leute
haben in diesem moment der beispielhaft
firma ganzes leben steht mal wieder
nicht an mich geglaubt was habe ich
gemacht ich hab mir gesagt wissen was
leute [ __ ] euch ich mach das versetze
mich auf probe und sie haben mich auf
probe versetzt man sagt die ersten zwei
monate wenn deine noten da okay sind
kannst du in der neunten klasse bleiben
wenn nicht geht es zurück in die achte
und was habe ich gemacht leute ich habe
mich reingehängt und ich hab's geschafft
sind ich habe nicht nur die neu
geschaffene geschafft die elfte die
zwölfte habe ein gutes abi hingelegt und
studiert seiner sehr guten uni
das ist einfach eine geschichte von
vielen aus meinem leben und die haben
mich mit zudem bewegt das merchandise
für euch zu machen dann kommen wir jetzt
mal zu den artikeln diesem store zu
haben geben
wird das ist als allererstes dass hier
der babyblues länger krunic mit dem
weißen print der wird streng limitiert
auf eine sehr sehr sehr geringe
stückzahl seien und wenn ich es sage
dann meine ich es auch wirklich so also
ich bin nicht so dass ich sage hey leute
des limitierten dann habe ich hinten
raus 10.000 pullover nein da wird
wirklich streng limitiert sein
und ich glaube das wird eine richtig
geile sache sein weil wisst ihr was
dieses blau erkennt man einfach gut mit
dem rudi dann auf dem video days oder
sowas umwelt dann seht ihr untereinander
sofort wer wirklich die hardcore palace
und werden dieses streng limitierte
merchandise gekauft hat und bei mir
natürlich genauso ich werde natürlich
den polier behalten dann haben wir so
eine kleine kerngruppe von leuten die
einfach alle denselben merchandise haben
den sonst niemand hat und es wird glaube
ich richtig richtig geil wie gesagt der
baby blue kunick streng limitiert der
ist dazu noch megane eis geschnitten
finde ich und biss von ihnen aufgebaut
was mir persönlich sehr wichtig ist
kaufe nur policen beim matchball die
auch von den aufgebaut sind weil ich
einfach finde das ist einfach geil das
muss einfach sagt ich hab bei der
bestellung so viele dinge rausgeworfen
die ähnlich aufgebaut waren
mir geht es wirklich nur den code dann
machen wir weiter
das t shirt ist einer von drei artikel
es wird insgesamt drei klamotten artikel
in diesem shop geben warum fragt ihr
euch vielleicht ich denke mir ganz
einfach wisst ihr was aber das design
bis design ist mega schlicht aber es
trotzdem einfach nice genau so denke ich
mir als auch bei der anzahl der produkte
ist einfach weniger mehr man hat einfach
eine kleine aber dafür richtig richtig
neiße kollektion weil ich persönlich
denke das leben schon kompliziert genug
dann braucht man einfach simple aber
geile mode
dafür stehen aber schauen was ist hier
schon mal genauer an das unter fairtrade
bedingungen produziert und diese auf
dollar am arm sind nicht vorgelegt das
heißt ihr könnt ihr aber selbst
entscheiden ob er die dinge auf rollen
wollt ich traue ihm übrigens auch zu
dass ihr die auch selbst aufräumen
können liebe leute aus rollen auf wollen
das ist eine welt noch etwas hat es noch
nie gegeben
die ersten in deutschland die das
gemacht haben
aber aber regiert ist doch mit unserem
china chinas tor gemacht oder also sehen
wir die ersten deutschland wir sind die
ersten deutschen aber wirklich das t
shirt einer von drei artikeln einfach
ich find's einfach doch ich glaube merkt
einfach ich bin auch von dem scheiß
überzeugt ich habe selbst gemacht ich
fand den geil und er ist einfach gut in
meinen augen dass hier leute ist der
dritte artikel der rudi genau wie das t
shirt wird den rudi in weiß wird im
schwarzen aufdruck geben die beiden
artikel wird auch in größeren
stückzahlen geben nur der baby blue tec
stark limitiert das hier ist so die wahl
für alle die sagen okay wir wollen
vielleicht auch keine limitierte edition
überall einfach richtig gut ist haben
wir wollen es fällt doch nicht zu herzen
mit dem stellung für euch ist das hier
und das genauso natürlich cosinus faktor
von innen aufgeraut selbstverständlich
ich trage das gerade einfacher ohne t
shirt und es ist einfach toll ist durch
die auf frauen in mega warm und sitzt
einfach auch sehr nice und übrigens
leute mega viel habe mich auch schon
gefragt so hell wie ist es mit der größe
ich trage normalerweise ältere police
auch ne also fällt ganz normal aus hier
von so vielen leuten gehört hey des
möchten das gefällt mir voll gut das
sind wir das einzige mädchen das was
auch einfach optisch gut aussieht dass
man nicht nur kauf weil ein fan von den
youtube was man auch wirklich einfach so
tragen kann
in klamotten leute die zieht männchen zu
schlafen sondern damit kann man wirklich
einfach sauber auf die straße raus gehen
das baby blue mitte weiß hier mit dem
schwarzen prinzip auch ein preis aus ist
einfach coole leute ich bin einer von
dem scheiß überzeugt den märkten und bei
dieser ganzen sache leute war kein
unternehmen bei keine institutionen die
sich da irgendwie ein anteil ab zweck es
war einfach nur ich bin ein kumpel nur
wir beide haben das gemacht sonst
niemand im ersten 12 201 16 00 uhr geht
mein shop online und ab dem ersten 12
2016 00 uhr könnt ihr meinen merchandise
kaufen
für genau eine woche der ganze store
wird nur eine woche online sein
es ist super exklusiv nach einer woche
schließt das tor wieder man kann das
alles nie wieder erwerben
deswegen werde davon was haben wollt
leute bald durch den wärme nicht nur
limitierte stückzahl auf manche artikel
sondern wir haben auch noch eine woche
bestellt seit nach dieser woche ist
schluss wenn die besteller fertig
gemacht
gar nichts mehr rein nichts mehr raus
aber ich sage heute ich bin einfach so
halb das ganze team passt einfach von
vorne bis hinten das ist nicht einfach
irgendein abgefragt das ding und geld
verdienen das ist wirklich was in der
dem ich zu 100 prozent stil einfach weil
ich von anfang an bis zum ende begleitet
habe und leute wenn ich von anfang an
bis zum ende begleitet sage dann meine
ich das auch so denn auch die
auslieferung werde ich bei drei
bestellungen persönlich machen das heißt
leute ich werd drei bestellung aus einem
bestimmungen die eingehen zufällig
auswählen und diesen drei leuten welche
bestellungen persönlich vorbeibringen
wie werde ich das machen
irgendein auto schnappen wird mir eure
bestellungen nehmen wenn sie in den
kofferraum reinpacken deckel zu wertlos
waren und wer drei bestellungen
persönlich mit meinem auto bei euch
deutschland und österreich vorbeibringen
fans egal wo es ist meinetwegen fahrt
von hamburg nach wien 15 stunden
scheißegal leute drei bestellungen
werden von mir persönlich ausgeliefert
einfach weil es was ist in dem ich zu
100 prozent steht also wie gesagt leute
erst 12 2016 ab 0 uhr öffnen die
bestellung wenn ihr sicher gehen wollen
dass ihr baby blue coat bekommt oder
dass ihr das t shirt größe zu 100
prozent hinbekommen könnte ja keine
ahnung bis mitternacht kämpfen und
mitternacht bestellung ein klatschen
wenn auch schon ein paar leute
geschrieben dass sie das machen wollen
ich bin einfach so froh leute es
torleute es platten kommt es auf jeden
fall 20.000 mal und in der beschreibung
verlinkt empfindet jeder auf jeden fall
auch und können auch mal abchecken was
ja sogar findet am ende werde ich drei
lieferungen persönlich rausbringen
kriebstein laufen bis zum 8 12
wie gesagt ich habe die arbeit jetzt
reingesteckt und jetzt übergebe ich das
ganze an euch jetzt dürft ihr
entscheiden wie es damit abläuft wie es
euch gefällt ich viele davon haben wollt
wer wie viel davon handeln ist jetzt
alles an euch ich übergebe quasi die
entscheidungen und ich bin mehr gespannt